soit si rihanna et merci de me proposer
de réagir dans votre émission était pmp
ce matin sur europe 1 j'ai signalé le
problème démocratique que pose le
système des parrainages comme vous le
savez pour être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
la loi impose de recueillir 500
signatures d'élus ce sont des députés
des sénateurs des députés européens des
conseillers départementaux des
conseillers régionaux mais ce sont
surtout les maires de toutes les
communes de france mais ce système de
parrainage a été perverti par françois
hollande car désormais les noms des
mères qui parraine un candidat sont
systématiquement rendu public la
conséquence est simple de nombreux élus
subissent des pressions ils ont peur par
exemple que la région leur retire des
aides pour leur commune tenait ce matin
encore un sénateur heller a envoyé un
courrier de menaces au maire de son
département cette loi ne remplit plus
son rôle elle ne sert plus qu'à museler
les candidats qui ne sont pas issus du
sérail politique
je ne dénonce pas à cette loi que pour
mes seuls intérêts bien sûr je souhaite
pouvoir me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle pour représenter des
millions de français et qu'ensemble d
avril 2022 nous engageons la reconquête
de notre pays mais je considère aussi
qu'il n'est pas normal que marine le pen
ou bien jean luc mélenchon et des
difficultés à obtenir leur part inna
c'est un déni de démocratie est une
violation du principe d'égalité des
candidats avec reconquête nous
représentons aujourd'hui des millions de
français sur tout le territoire dans
chaque département je demande aux
français qui regardent votre émission
trouvez vous normal qu'un candidats
crédités à à près de 15 % dans les
sondages représentant des millions de
français ne puisse finalement pas se
présenter parce que il lui manquerait
500 signatures je tiens également à le
marteler haut et fort je ne serai
l'otage de personne et ne participerait
à aucune combine politicienne c'est
pourquoi j'en appelle à l'association
des maires de france dirigée par david
lisnard monsieur listener vous devez
vous saisir de ce dossier
et créer un recueil de signatures qui
sera allouée aux candidats crédité d'au
moins 5% des voix dans les derniers
sondages vous permettrait ainsi à chaque
français d'être représenté dans cette
élection présidentielle en attendant
j'appelle dès maintenant les maires de
france à parrainer ma candidature et à
ne pas laisser des millions de français
se faire voler l'élection présidentielle
je remercie du fond du coeur les élus
qui ont déjà signé la promesse de
parrainage ainsi que mes équipes qui
sont sur le terrain pour rencontrer
chaque jour les maires et les élus de la
république
merci pour votre soutien